[Music]
so I've always been fascinated by the
relationship between creativity and
madness right like Timothy Leary
famously said in order to use your head
you've got to go out of your mind now
this of course implies kind of
willingness to sort of go to unknown
places to visit mental landscapes that
are alien willingness to sort of leave
ones comforts to decondition one's
thinking one's reflexive responses to
stimuli to go to other realms of the
mind catalyzing the imagination is like
diving headfirst toward the unknown and
there's always a potential of getting
hurt you know it is said that the mystic
and the madman are swimming in the same
waters but the mystic you know he's like
an artist surfing it down he's bringing
back visions he's bringing back
souvenirs from these ecstatic spaces and
places but you know at the end of the
day the artist does become depleted the
artist is sacrificing part of himself to
bring back those visions to create a
phase change in the consciousness of
society he leaves the consensus trance
he leaves our cultural operating systems
he shows us different reality tunnels
that gives us a sense of perspective us
as consumers of art we pay money for
them to take us to spaces that we cannot
go by ourselves
these are heroes these are cultural
luminaries they are their Mad Men that
somehow have been able to to sort of
cope and domesticate them in evidence
and towards useful ends you know this
idea of always having functional output
you know to go to Oz you know it's a
tumble down that rabbit hole and somehow
you know return to tell the tale
[Music]